foreign
CDC the shadow CDC yes right all right
well maybe I should do that having uh
encountered the shadow CDC in person and
in fact being uh
I guess a member of it yes and being
shattered right now by an epic Tabby yes
I am
um so what has happened is Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida has made several
announcements
um he is pursuing a grand jury
investigation of
um malfeasance during covid
um he's doing that uh
as uh Florida's governor the idea being
that Floridians were harmed like every
other group and that we should uh check
out these
um these harms and figure out uh how
they arose and
in any case he has also announced a I'm
not sure I love the term Shadow CDC
frankly I'm not even sure that that is a
term that uh came out officially but
those who are involved with it I've seen
you've seen headlines so what it is is
it's a group of folks with various
different kinds of expertise who have
been impaneled to essentially talk about
what we should be doing with respect to
covet and to comment on what we have
been doing and uh to uh to compare these
things because many of us of course many
Dark Horse listeners in fact all
long-standing dark horse listeners and
viewers will know that we've been quite
disturbed by the policy that has emerged
in the aftermath
um of code so I travel to policy policy
is one after another yes all of the
policies
um that uh have followed the emergence
of covis the covet the official
emergence being
um the very final days of 2019 uh many
of us believe that the actual emergence
of the virus was quite a bit earlier
than that
um in fact that there is strong evidence
that what it was circulating at the
Wuhan military games in September I'm
virtually sure it was September of 2019.
so that is among the many errors our
failure to acknowledge that the virus
was circulating uh early is certainly on
that list with significant consequences
um so maybe Zach are you ready to show
that clip we thought it was important
particularly me talking with other
Governors to say okay because CDC will
say these things and then people will
think well because they're saying it
then we have to do it and maybe not
quite as much anymore because people
have lost confidence but you still see
it we had to fight it with the masking
in the schools because the the school
districts were citing CDC as the reason
why they wanted to do it we had to come
and overrule that but it was difficult
because they were being put as an
authority and some people were were
doing that so other Governors and I have
talked about the need uh to have a panel
of experts who can counteract nonsense
when it's coming out of these
institutions that are not going to just
go along with the flow and follow
pre-cooked narratives but will actually
do evidence-based analysis and so in
Florida we're creating uh what we're
calling the public health Integrity
committee it's a committee of x expert
researchers that will be able to assess
recommendations and guidance related to
Public Health and health care but
particularly being able to offer
critical assessments of things that
bureaucracies like the FDA CDC and NIH
are doing we know that there's been a
lot of faith destroyed in public health
and I think that it's important that we
have folks who people actually can rely
on when they're looking to answers and
when they're looking for guidance on
some of these really really important
issues the people we have today
bhattacharya caldorf Hogue Freeman
Christine stable Ben Weinstein Templeton
are all going to be on this on this
panel and so I think you're going to see
a lot of other states are going to join
with us to be able to work and so it's
not just going to be helping Florida
it's going to be helping people all
throughout the United States of America
America Governor DeSantis and his
Surgeon General Dr ladapo is that his
name I should have asked him in person
how to pronounce it but it's either
ladapa or latapo okay I've heard it
pronounced both ways uh pulled together
a group of
um scientists and doctors and medical
doctors
include I don't know if you want to just
mention I would say a few people people
are likely to know uh Jay bhattacharya
is on it Martin koldorf is on it uh I
was on it
um I don't know how I'm gonna pronounce
Tracy's last name it's it's basically
like a Kong name and you have to have
special phonemes in order to get there
but I think the way we traditionally
butchered in English is Tracy Hogue
um Christine stable Ben is on it anyway
it's a and I'm I think there are others
yet to come on the group uh so stay
tuned to see who arrives there but it's
a lot of people who have made important
contributions Jay bharachara and Martin
koldorf of course being
uh primary authors of the Great
Barrington declaration Christine stable
Ben being somebody who our viewers and
listeners will be familiar with from her
excellent unheard uh interview and we
discussed her work revealing that the
MRNA vaccines appear to have to cause an
increase in all-cause mortality
um so anyway all of these people were
gathered several of them virtually there
were I don't know I guess uh six of us
there in person
and we had some back and forth and
um
we had several people we had some
vaccine injured folks tell their story
as well it's quite heart-wrenching to
hear what these people have been through
and as I've said many times the
gaslighting of the vaccine injured is
the most among the most shocking things
to emerge in this whole uh in this whole
pandemic because it really requires a
willingness on the part of governmental
bureaucrats to insist that people take a
remedy and then uh pretend that they
have not been injured which just seems
you know one struggles to find words
other than diabolical for that level of
callousness yeah it's it's analogous
it's an imperfect analogy but it's
analogous
to not taking care of your veterans
it is it is exactly the same thing and
how it is that these bureaucrats do not
understand that we will look at how the
vaccine injured were treated and then
the next time they tell us well here's a
vaccine that you must take
right that cannot help but be a primary
factor it would be a factor for any
intelligent person they're creating
actual anti-vaxxers they are creating
they are creating real anti-vaxxness and
you know and they are they are um
fueling it right they are giving it a
credible reason to exist which
is an unthinkable error on their part
there were a number of things I wanted
to discuss it's a Pity the the clip
isn't working
um but I will say in my introduction I
argued
that the decision making in and around
covid from the decision to find the
ancestor virus in the wild to bring it
into the lab to enhance its capacity to
infect humans
then they lost control of it presumably
and it got into the human population
they failed to acknowledge that it was
taking place that evidence is
increasingly clear and then they
deployed a strangely top-down response
to this virus which presumably they knew
very little about its effect on humans
because presumably they had not seen it
in humans until it got into somebody and
left the lab so for them to have a
top-down response ready and to enforce
it you know coercively aggressively on
the medical profession is an insane
inversion of the normal order normally
if you had some disease if some disease
really had left out of nature and had
begun infecting humans the people who
would be in the best position to tell
you how to deal with it would be doctors
who had been treating it clinically and
while those doctors would at first have
known nothing what they would have done
is they would have followed hunches they
would have looked at symptoms they would
have said ah this symptom is failing
here are some Pharmaceuticals that are
useful in treating that symptom they
would have deployed those things
deployed techniques some of them would
have worked some of them would not have
worked they would have discussed what
they had seen what they thought was
working you know with other doctors at
the water cooler or and that that we
would have gotten good at treating it to
have it come down from above meant that
process didn't happen and the argument
for for instance lockdowns and mandatory
Universal basking in many places
looks much different if this is just
emerging and we got to shut down travel
and we got to shut down borders and we
got to shut down everything
or this has actually been circulating
for half a year already and now we got
to do this right away we got to do this
as urgent right like you can't create a
sense of urgency in a populace if you
tell them this has been out there for
six months
not only can you not create it but the
utility of trying it is already gone
um this is one of the points that that
Jay bought sorry yeah there's there's
two different there's two different
things like could this potentially be
useful and is it possible to implement
this on a population and those should be
you know you shouldn't you you shouldn't
think about implementing it unless it
could be useful but but they are really
two you know one of them is Downstream
or the other but you need to satisfy
both of those criteria before you decide
to do it before you would decide to do
anything so disruptive yeah and
um so I will Point people to you know
why would they have delayed once the
thing had escaped it seems like uh time
is of the essence and you want people to
be a you know how much time was wasted
doctors seeing a disease that they
didn't know was novel and therefore were
not categorizing it as novel and not
learning the things that they might have
been learning about what to deal with it
right that's one amongst a dozen
different problems that emerge when you
delay that um that awareness
so why would they have delayed it well I
would invite people to go back and look
at our discussion of the time traveling
money printer hypothesis right because
it may be that this was the cynical
recognition by those who did not alert
us that there was something circulating
that they had an opportunity that if
they were willing to uh
prevent us from deploying a rational
response that they were in an excellent
economic position to anticipate the
future and that there's a lot of ways to
turn that into money that was episode
150 incidentally I strongly encourage
people to go back and consider whether
or not that is the explanation but I did
want to highlight one thing from this
um
this meeting in Florida
we first of all I will say there is a
wide range of opinion on this panel I
would say everybody there is a coveted
dissident but we've all arrived at our
positions independently and therefore
those are not the same positions and
this emerged in one interesting place
that I wanted to point to
so in my introduction I argued that from
the sourcing of the ancestral virus in
the wild the enhancing its capacity with
gain of function research and then the
decision making around how to treat it
once it had emerged into the into the
human population
at all told that constitutes the largest
blunder in human history and I believe
it does constitute the largest blunder
in human history there are some equally
terrible or Worse incidents but they're
not blunders so in any case I made this
argument and Martin koldorf picked up on
it and he said Dr Weinstein is right
this is the largest blunder in public
health history or something like that or
words to that effect and we didn't get a
chance there wasn't enough time to have
an interaction about it but what I wish
I had been able to say and mind you
there's nothing negative here about
Martin I I'm a big fan of his work and I
tremendously appreciate the courage he
has shown and the Insight that he has
delivered during the pandemic but he
misunderstood what I said I said it was
the largest blunder in human history and
he took that to be in a medical context
and I wanted to
um
defend my position a little bit so that
people can understand so one of the
things that we did disagree on within
the panel is whether or not there was a
role for the so-called vaccines in a
rational response to covet and my
position is these vaccines these
vaccines these vaccines right well I
would have loved to have seen a vaccine
that was worth that label that did not
require for example a redefinition of
the term vaccine in order for it to
apply but what we got was a technology
that turned our bodies into vaccine
factories right that's a highly novel
phenomenon and the question is okay
given what they were given what we think
that we thought we understood about
their efficacy
um was there a role for those
Technologies to play and others on the
panel argue that there was a role that
for people who had uh
um comorbidities that made them
especially vulnerable these things might
well have been Justified and I take the
position that these were prototypes that
should never have been injected to human
beings and what I want
to make the argument I want to make now
to clarify why this distinction exists
I believe that those who disagree with
me on this point are
functioning Downstream of a very
honorable and correct Instinct but it
has been miswired not in them but in our
entire context
and what it what it is is I would just
simply say this
if it is true
that the facts of these Technologies the
actual facts of how effective they are
and how dangerous they are mean that
they should not have been emergency use
authorized then it is inherently true
that they should have been given to no
one and my point is given what we know
about these things now given what the
the facts that we have we have learned
as a result of what happened when they
were deployed at wide scale I think it's
very clear that emergency use
authorization made no sense given this
pathogen there was no justification for
taking something that has as many
negative consequences and a serious a
set of negative consequences well and
given that by the time the euas for the
vaccines were being considered there had
been many months of work by clinicians
by by doctors on the ground with
patients discovering what worked and
what didn't and those protocols have
changed over time as the virus has
evolved both because viruses evolve and
presumably because we put greater
selective pressure on it by vaccinating
the population
but the fact is that there were and
remain treatments and given the language
of the emergency use authorization from
the federal government which I read from
back in
gosh it would have been early 2021 on on
Dark Horse
um there was actually like just that
right there suggests that there was no
justification for an eua because there
were effective treatments available
right that's a that's an excellent point
so this is one of several points that
that had in the same direction one is
what we now see is that even in the
trials that argue that these things were
safe and effective
um the the evidence that they were
neither safe nor effective was already
present and so in light of that an
emergency use authorization should not
be granted the fact that we had safe and
effective treatments among the
repurposed drugs in and of itself should
have killed off the emergency use
authorization and given that they
shouldn't have been given to anybody so
in any case
giving them to people at wide scale in a
completely indifferent way with respect
to the age stratification of the risks
of the vaccines so-called vaccines
um and the risk stratification in
exactly the inverse form in their
potential value
these things should have been DOA they
should never have been authorized and in
light of that the authorization and
everything Downstream of it strikes me
as illegitimate
foreign
[Music]